alors ces nouvelles restrictions
sanitaires peuvent-elles se montrait
efficace c'est le débat de ce soir on en
parle avec nos deux invités et nous
savons avec jean philippe dugoin clément
mary dei de mennecy vice-président du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france et
olivier claude au maire divers droite de
yerres dans l'essonne bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
olivier que donc ce nouveau confinement
vous le contester comme l'année dernière
vous avez pris un arrêté autorisant
l'ensemble des commerces de proximité de
votre commune à rester ouverts il y a un
nom la justice l'avait annulée ce que
vous pensez vraiment qu'il en sera
autrement cette fois ci ce temps on va
voir ce que le tribunal administratif
décide à eelv a jugé ce qui est certain
c'est que mon arrêté que j'ai pris hier
elle était attaquée ce soir voyez il ya
quelques minutes la part le par le
préfet dont je peux je peux vous
l'annoncer c'est sans surprise il est
évident qu'ils allaient l'attaquer
on attend maintenant l'avis du tribunal
je ne désespère pas et je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que par rapport à vos
premiers arrêtés prix de l'année
dernière il ya il ya une nouveauté il ya
quelque chose qui change je pense c'est
qu'il ya jeu il y a vraiment une
distorsion entre la possibilité que les
commerces ont de pouvoir travailler
c'est à dire que moi je ne comprends pas
en quoi il serait plus dangereux
sanitairement parlant d' aller acheter
des chaussures d'aller acheter un bijou
une montre achetée son bijoutiers ou ou
d'aller dans son institut de beauté
plutôt que d'aller chez le coiffeur ou
chez le libraire ou chez le boulanger
c'est quelque chose qu'il faudra qu'on
m'explique
moi je pense qu'il y avait un réel un
réel problème sur ce point et donc
pourquoi j'ai pris vous arrêtez que j'ai
pris mon arrêté parce que sur le plan
sanitaire interdire quelques magasins la
soirée était il ya très peu de magasins
interdit par rapport à ce qu'on nous
avait proposé jeudi qui a été abordé
vendredi vent doit dire nous a dit
finalement les coiffeurs peuvent ouvrir
pierre quoi nous a dit finalement les
fleuristes peuvent rester ouverts puis
après on nous a dit des cordonniers
aussi aujourd'hui il reste grosso modo
les marchands de chaussures les
chausseurs
les marchands de vêtements et les
instituts de beauté voilà il reste les
restes de trois 3 types de commerces qui
doivent rester fermées au nom de quoi et
pourquoi est ce que on attrape plus
facilement le virus alors d'allemands
jeté une paire de chaussures comme halo
à la boulangerie qui ont alors acheté un
livre afin qu'on m'explique pourquoi
j'ai pris l arrêter oui il me semble
logique et de bon sens et ouverture pour
tous les commerces de proximité qui
respectent scrupuleusement les règles
sanitaires
le basque le gel la distance entre les
clients un faible nombre de clients dans
le magasin et le flux autres et soi
disant la boutique et on va poser la
question à jean philippe dugoin clément
en quoi fermer certains commerces freine
l'épidémie est ce que l'exode des
franciliens hier soit finalement ne
risque pas de propager tout autant le
virus et cette fois ci en dehors de
l'ile-de-france
pour tous ceux qui ont été sur les
routes y r quand on voit les fils les
gauchos colossaux des cas qui avait la
sortie de paris oui on peut se poser la
question du transport de la peau des
lits dans d'autres régions de la part de
transilien qui inquiétait par une
annonce de confinement qui ont déjà eu à
subir le confinement numéro un le
confinement numéro 2 n'ont qu'un souhait
c'est d'essayer de le passer dans des
conditions où un pénible alors ensuite
sur le confinement version 3 tel qu'il
nous est présenté comme souvent on est
confronté à une difficulté de cohérence
ce qui a été fait sur des commerces et
qui justifient l'arrêté de milliers
clodong à lierre en fait c'est on habite
tellement d'exceptions à la règle que
ceux qui se retrouvent à se faire
appliquer la règle sont quasiment
devenus eux-mêmes l'exception et donc ça
crée un sentiment d'incompréhension et
d'injustice absolument terrible pour les
commerces qui sont touchés en quoi on
autorise un cordonnier painchaud soeur
on peut se poser la question et je crois
que ce qui est terrible aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya un problème divisibilité
les mesures qui sont données on est sur
un pas de deux en permanence jeudi soir
on annonce un confinement
et puis vendredi samedi matin on
recharge les listes de commerce concerné
on annonce une attestation et puis plus
d'attestation on voit qu'il ya quand
même toute une part d'improvisation ce
qui est extrêmement surprenant est que
c'est pas quelque chose qui peut inciter
les français à votre confiance
alors après moi je dirai tout simplement
que le confinement c'est la solution en
bout de course qui la dernière chose qui
rêve quand on est en situation d'échec
que c'est quelque chose qui a des
conséquences économiques sociales
cichy absolument colossal et à partir du
moment où l'état décidé de le mettre il
faut comme le fait la région
d'ile-de-france comme le font les autres
régions comme le font les communes les
départements les intercommunalités
mettre en place des moyens massifs pour
accompagner ceux qui vont sauter hors
stations de souffrance aggravé le par
cette décision politique le dong-a au
delà du manque de cohérence et de clarté
de ses troupes autour de la liste de
commerce essentiel autorisée à rouvrir
qu'est ce qui a réellement motivé votre
décision de maintenir à l'ensemble des
commerces de votre commune ou verser un
ras-le-bol de la population comment
est-ce qu'elle a réagi d'ailleurs à ce
nouveau ca de ce nouvel arrêté vous avez
pris hier la population très bien réagi
d'abord les commerçants et bien beau
très bien réagi mais ça ça vous
surprendra pas mais la population a très
bien réagi et est venu en nombre
aujourd'hui faire ses courses et c'est
très bien non moi j'ai pris cet arrêté
pas pour les questions de ras-le-bol
mais pour des raisons de la
compréhension ce qui se passe et jean
philippe dugoin clément l'a très bien
dit est totalement incohérent si on ne
sait pas où on va
ah le jeudi à 18 heures on nous donne
une feuille de route qu'on modifie le
jeudi à 20h pour modifier le vendredi à
8 heures du matin quand on modifie
encore à 14h corbeau diffile samedi
c'est à dire que une merde il
retrouverait pas ses petits
donc en fait ce qui a motivé vous l'art
et essai de la clarté voilà moi j'allais
arrêter ça claire qui est tous les
commerces de proximité qui respecte les
conditions sanitaires peuvent rester
ouverts
voilà c'est simple c'est limpide et il
n'y a pas si vous voulez de ya pas de
2,2 de questions à se poser
mais au-delà de ça si vous permettez le
sentiment qui domine et les mois ce qui
m'affole le plus quelque part c'est de
voir à quel point on tape à chaque fois
à côté de la plaque enfin l'état à
chaque fois à côté de la plaque
on a eu le problème pour les mains ask
moi j'ai suivi un jeu vous dire les
masques qui ont permis deux que j'ai pu
donner
les habitants les écoles aux personnes
qui produit le rer chez moi pour aller
travailler le matin ce sont les basques
de la ville du département et de la
région ile-de-france pas les basques de
l'êta
l'état nous a dit simplement comme ne
vous inquiétez pas on vous remboursera
entre parenthèses on attend toujours le
remboursement on n'a toujours pas été
payés des basques de l'an dernier ça a
été pareil pour le gel ça a été pareil
pour l'ensemble des éléments dont on a
besoin c'est à dire que on a un état qui
fait de grandes annonces et après qui
fait le boulot sur le terrain je vais
vous dire ce sont les mairies les
départements en tout cas le département
des sols et la région ile de france
voilà la réalité voilà ce qui allait
agissent sur le terrain au quotidien et
c'est pareil les vies de nos commerçants
aujourd'hui moi je voudrais qu'à
représentant de l'état monsieur castex
ou qui que ce soit venez nous dire en
quoi il est plus dangereux d'aller faire
ses courses c'est la chose leur que chez
un fleuriste
moi j'attends je voudrais qu'on me donne
la réponse je vous promets que
l'exécutif se targue depuis plusieurs
semaines de concerter davantage les élus
locaux pour territorialisée ces mesures
est ce que c'est le cas concrètement
dans les faits jean philippe dugoin
clément vous qui êtes maire mais aussi
est vice-président du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france vous avez été concertée
non on est le culte des lieux on n'est
plus sûr de l'information en mode course
que sur la concertation c'est à dire que
les associations d'élus l'association
des maires d'île de france
les grands élus entre guillemets
franciliens qu'il s'agisse de la région
du département ont été appelés entre le
mercredi soir et le jeudi matin pour
leur dire qu'est ce que vous pensez d'un
confinement 7 jours sur 7 et d'un
confinement le week-end en abaissant
l'heure du couvre-feu
mais c'est très caricatural sait on est
quasiment mis quelques heures avant
devant des hypothèses vous dira pas
véritablement choix et où est la limite
le la question de la concertation c'est
patent là dessus c'est pas aux élus
locaux qui n'ont pas les données
statistiques nationales ons pas
forcément la pression aux italiennes en
ligne de course sont pas les données
scientifiques le décider de la mesure à
prendre
par contre les modalités de son
application elle ne peut pas être fait
sans les élus locaux
quand on prend sur les écoles sur les
cantines sur les périscolaires sur les
équipements sportifs
sur les équipements culturels sur les
équipements commerciaux qu'on évoque là
dessus c'est tout un travail de mise en
place à l'infra qui devrait être
beaucoup plus fait alors après il ya
quand même des points sur lesquels
effectivement on peut se réjouir des
déplacés qu' il ya une
territorialisation par région on éviter
de traiter la france entière comme
c'était le cas au mois de mars dernier à
la même aune alors que ça ne se
justifiait pas on a quand même réussi à
si c'est parce que les élus ont été
entendus mais il était le couvre-feu
soit abaissé à 17 heures ce qui est pas
une des premières choses qui nous ont
été donnés mercredi soir et jeudi matin
puisqu'il a même été repoussé à 19
heures c'est ce qui rend d'ailleurs
d'autant plus incompréhensible les
commerces y sont fermées c'est que
globalement on voit bien qu'on est sur
un confinement qui a relâché beaucoup de
choses il y en avait un couvre-feu de
18h il passe à 19 heures on a réouvert
les activités sportives pour les enfants
scolaires et non scolaires donc on est
plutôt sur un relâchement et le
confinement il consiste en quoi la
limitation des 10 km mais qui est
uniquement des idées créatives
le fait de ne pas sortir de région est
fermé des commerces qui se retrouve
encore une fois être les plus impactés
alors qu'on est sur les secteurs les
plus fragilisés on a vraiment un souci
de cohérence et d'adaptation des mesures
au niveau local de prise en compte de la
réelle et des choses dans les communes à
l'infra territoriale la façon dont ça
fonctionne véritablement derniers mois à
vous deux assez rapidement si vous
voulez bien parce que le temps nous
manque on en sort comment de cette crise
ça passera par un coup de boost de la
vaccination
jean philippe dugoin clément sont
aujourd'hui la seule solution c'est
d'augmenter la cadence de vaccination
faut absolument qu'on arrive à pousser
les feux sur ce sujet là et puis on a
quand même des sujets de fond qu'on
aurait dû commencer à traiter depuis un
an qu'on n'a pas fait c'est de réarmer
le système hospitalier qui a été
affaiblie depuis 20 ans c'est de
réindustrialiser notre industrie
pharmaceutique pour être moins client
captif de l'extérieur de l'étranger on a
ces sujets de fond à traiter mais sur le
court terme c'est la vaccination partage
ce point de vue olivier que le don vous
misez la sortie de crise
repose sur la stratégie de vaccination
je recommence le nia jean-philippe c'est
évident le combat aujourd'hui il est là
c'est la baptisation en deux la
vaccination en trois la vaccination chez
le combat d'urgence c'est ce qu'il faut
mener il faut parvenir à vacciner et à
augmenter le rythme des vaccinations de
nos concitoyens c'est la seule façon
aujourd'hui de s'en sortir correctement
et après effectivement sur le moyen
terme voire une vraie réflexion sur la
problématique de nos lits de réanimation
sur la problématique de l'équipement nos
hôpitaux de la formation de nos médecins
c'est fondamental mais aujourd'hui il ya
cabossé la vaccination merci beaucoup à
tous les deux messieurs olivier que le
dong maire divers droite de yerres dans
l'essonne jean philippe dugoin clément
mais rude et de mennecy et
vice-président du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france merci d'avoir pris le
temps d'échanger ce soir avec nous sur
rt france